Bienvenidos en 5 minutos burkina faso
siguió los pasos de Mali y pidió a las
tropas francesas que salgan de su
territorio a esto se suman
manifestaciones en las que ciudadanos de
esta y otras ex colonias francesas
queman banderas de Francia mientras
abrazan las rusas y piden la ayuda de
este país tras sangrientos años de
ataques yihadistas en el
en este video les explicamos Qué es el
conflicto lensagel y Por qué las tropas
francesas hacen presencia en esta región
Comencemos para entender Qué es el
sagelio esta región abarca una decena de
países de África subsahariana y va desde
el Océano Atlántico hasta el mar rojo es
una zona golpeada por la extrema pobreza
y en la que diversos grupos yihadistas
como el estado islámico o al qaeda
tienen fuerte presencia en los últimos
años el conflicto ha dejado unos 25 mil
muertos y más de 3 millones de
refugiados La amenaza arrancó en 2012 en
el norte de Mali pero hoy en día dos
terceras partes del país están bajo
dominio de estos grupos
burkinager corren en la misma suerte y
otros países como togo Benin y Costa de
Marfil ella también han sufrido
atentados
en este escenario y para frenar La
amenaza de al qaeda en Mali en 2012
Francia junto a otros países africanos
iniciaron una operación militar que
llamaron serval Entonces los islamistas
gobernaban de facto todo el norte del
país en 2014 inició la operación barcana
Que siguió a serval y se extendió
también a urquina faso Niger Chad y
mauritania en esta colaboró Francia
junto a otros socios europeos y cinco
países del sahell Mali mauritania
burkina faso níger y Chad en total
Francia desplegó 5.100 soldados esta
operación no fue solicitada en un
momento en el que los gobiernos
africanos no podían hacerse cargo de La
amenaza de la expansión de diversos
grupos que pretendían imponer la ley
islámica aucharia en todo el país por
qué ahora varios países exigen el retiro
de Francia e incluso queman su bandera
hay varios factores la imposibilidad de
acabar con la violencia es los
principales la operación barcana fue
pensada inicialmente a corto plazo e
incluso tuvo varias victorias con la
eliminación de decenas de yihadistas y
recuperación de territorios pero ni
Francia ni la comunidad internacional ni
específicamente del gobierno de Malik
supieron como instaurar nuevamente la
presencia del estado y esto aumentó la
inestabilidad A falta de la presencia
Estatal los grupos fueron creciendo con
aliados entre las poblaciones locales ya
sea por temor o por simpatía para 2019
los yihadistas de al qaeda y el estado
islámico habían expandido su influencia
en Mali burkina faso y níjero según el
proyecto de datos de eventos y ubicación
de conflictos armados con sede en
Estados Unidos alrededor de 9000 muertes
tuvieron lugar en la región debido al
conflicto en 2022 frente a las 6000 del
año anterior sentimiento antifrances
muchos ciudadanos consideran que los
soldados franceses a pesar de pertenecer
a una potencia mundial no han logrado
dar solución al conflicto lo que ha
hecho crecer un sentimiento antifranceso
este también ha estado avivado por el
pasado colonial de Francia en estos
países y es que muchas personas se
equiparan ahora la presencia de tropas
galas en estos territorios a nuevas
formas de colonialismo golpes de estado
en Mali en agosto de 2020 el coronel
asimilita lideró un golpe militar contra
el presidente Ibrahim bubaquerqueida y
meses después se deshizo de los líderes
civiles del proceso de transición
prometiendo elecciones
algo parecido sucedió en burkina faso en
septiembre del año pasado el capital
Ibrahim travé se hizo con el poder acusó
al presidente Paul Angie y damiva de no
haber sido capaz de afrontar la crisis
de violencia y pobreza que azota al país
la fórmula Se repitió el pasado 21 de
enero en burkina faso la junta militar
dio las tropas francesas un mes para
concretar su retirada pero hay un último
factor clave el auge de la presencia
rusa en África las autoridades malienses
sellaron un acuerdo con el grupo Wagner
estos mercenarios han sido acusados de
violaciones a los Derechos Humanos
también son acusados de adelantar
operaciones de desinformación en redes
sociales en contra de occidente el
gobierno ruso niega todo vínculo con
bigner Estados Unidos y la Unión Europea
los consideran una fuerza no oficial que
busca extender la influencia rusa ahora
también en burkina indicios de que la
junta militar estaría negociando con el
grupo por el momento siguen abiertos los
interrogantes sobre si esta agrupación
logrará resolver el problema de larga
Data en los países del sahell Y es que
no cuenta con los mismos medios
militares de un ejército convencional y
su historial de violencia podría traer
aún más inseguridad a la región si le
sirvió el vídeo para dimensionar la
crisis de violencia en este territorio
los esperamos en otro episodio de en
cinco minutos en France 24 y France
24.com
[Música]